of course I'm wrong touring when driving
a Porsche over the floorboards over the
forum points way in the foreign tourists
getting abortion in the divorce at the
same time to hear and support him look
what I'm planning planning I'm planning
to doing this while you're panicking and
you're looking at staring at mannequins
and I'm going to sanic is trying to get
up a plan against all of the planner can
Santa can fan fan fan against what on
Avantika Santa can Hannah in a Cabana
you're gonna come I'm in a Cabana in the
Janet I'm gonna Cabana chant in order
stand a banner or you don't got to stand
on your leg and a stamina your lack of
the salmon don't want your divorce and
Harrison Ford and I'm in a portion of
flowing ports while I'm wrong torrent
using way too many napkins napkins
laughs kisses chappy you use the chance
to connect Consuela babkin flapping
around like a babkin slamming a baby
declaring a champion dam and a canopy